to actually explain that one has to go
sort of introduce the subject a little
broader tops a person I think most
people would agree is the person because
of in the end of of a person's brain
which is where people think plan and
we're all perceptions are collected and
possessed and I'm a neuroscientist I
work on how the brain works which is an
unbelievable a big challenge because
it's a really quite amazing organ in
principle how the brain works is easy
enough to explain it's billions and
billions of nervous cells that
constantly talk to each other and by
talking to each other process
information and at some point come to
some decision or doing something what we
have been doing over decades now ever
since I started science trying to
understand how nerve cells in the brain
communicate with each other so our
contribution to science and a broad
sense was to shed light on how a nerve
cell speaks to another nerve cell and
the way a nerve cell does that is via
the specialized connection that is
formed between these cells in the brain
and that connection is called a synapse
and the synapse transfers information
and processes information from one nerve
cell to the next it is a specialized
junction between nerve cells there is
not only there to relay information but
also to change information it's it's own
little nano computer if you want to call
it that and what we have done is to try
to understand better how one cell sends
out the information to the next at
synapse and ideally how also it
processes that information and our major
contributions I believe was in figuring
out the basic fundamental molecular
processes that govern this ability of a
nerve cell in all brain all brains in
all cells and in all animals
fundamentally our work deals with trying
to understand how brain cells
communicate yes and how exactly what's
the molecular basis what is what are the
genes how do they work what is the
atomic structure how are they regulate
how does their activity affect the
overall brain and how does that change
and disease